[Music]
the president's point man on the
Venezuela crisis says international
pressure will eventually lead to the
ouster of disputed president Nicolas
Maduro Special Representative Elliott
Abrams was on Capitol Hill today at
least one lawmakers seemed more
interested in the past than the present
State Department correspondent rich
Edson has the latest if I could respond
to that I am it wasn't a question the
Trump administration's new Venezuela
envoy defending his work in the Reagan
administration one of the newest members
of the House Foreign Affairs Committee
questioned Elliott Abrams credibility on
latin-american policy because of u.s.
involvement then in El Salvador civil
war yes or no do you think that massacre
was a fabulous achievement that happened
under our watch that is a ridiculous
question about yes or no no I I am NOT
going to respond to that kind of
personal attack as Abrams defends the
current administration's Latin American
policy disputed Venezuelan president
Nicolas Maduro refuses to yield power to
opposition leader and interim president
Juan Guido there is a storm brewing
inside the Maduro regime that will
eventually bring it to an end for those
remaining supporters of the regime we
have one simple message your time is up
much of Venezuela's military leadership
appears to support Maduro abram says now
is the time for the Armed Forces to
support the Venezuelan people
two weeks after National Security
Advisor John Bolton appeared in a
briefing with 5,000 troops to Colombia
clearly written on a notepad Abram says
the administration is not taking the
military route meeting this afternoon
with Colombian President Yvan Duque
President Trump refused to elaborate
five thousand troops to Colombia you'll
see the United States has sent food and
medicine to Colombia the United Nations
says more than 3 million Venezuelans
have fled during this economic crisis
many arrived here in neighboring cúcuta
Colombia in August Fox News traveled to
KUKA tub where tens of thousands of
Venezuelans crossed daily into Colombia
to secure medicine clean water and food
maderos government is blocking American
aid shipments they're claiming his
country is not a nation of beggar's
shouldn't leader Hwang Guido says he is
organizing aid caravans into Venezuela
starting February 23rd that gives the
military more than a week to decide
whether to try and stop them colombian
president davon Duque has committed to
ensuring that those caravans arrive
Brett Richardson live the State
Department rich tanks